[Musique]
bonjour de mode
vous avez vu cette entrée saurait
témoins ventre et de reus cinq ans de
cela 5 ans parce que je n'ose jamais ce
qu'on appelle la timidité maladive fait
que je ne n'avais peur de ne pas réussir
maintenant du ridicule voire tout temps
le public les yeux braqués sur moi
pourrait carrément d'écrire de ça et
pourtant sacré je suis là c'est une
façon de vous dire que tout le monde a
un potentiel
tout le monde attend mais beaucoup
d'entre nous ne s'est pas exprimé parce
qu'on a la chance de l'autre nous avons
des préjugés parce nous avons
éventuellement obs du regard des autres
je suis à et le thème de mon exposé
c'est comment réussir et vivre heureux
dans ce monde et je vais vous donner
juste les trois pensé que je pourrais
vous donner la première est bien fait en
sorte que je puisse pour parler
maintenant c'est éliminer vos barrières
vos propres barrières de la tête cette
phrase elle m'a été donnée par un
irlandais qui étaient partis en ir
l'autre je venais d'arriver ce dernier
pour qui sur price là où on perdait des
emplois tous les jours et moi je venais
dans le mettre dans un pays où non
l'anglais pam était approximatif et du
coup j'en voyais bcv et un jour vous
avez ce que des réponses négatives et un
jour je reçois un appel pour andy
écoutez on va vous prendre pour un
entretien
c'était un jeudi et notre charité pour
le match donc tout content d'avoir voir
cette réponse positive
donc j'ai pas fait attention
qui m'avait appelé et quand je regarde
le courrier de mails de convocation je
me rends compte que c'était un pur de
l'interprétation
alors que mon anglais était comme ça si
vous vous y mettez aussi un accent très
fort il désire garder on était un peu
nous étions pas très cool amis mais en
plus de cela c'était pour travailler
pour deux ministères de la justice et le
ministère de la santé
donc de quoi être empathique
combien et c'est là où dans un jardin un
vieux je m'appelle le père noël parce
qu'il y avait là bas c'était dans un
parc
il me regarde et me dis toi aujourd'hui
il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas donc
je lui dis calmement oui j'ai j'ai
envoyé mon cv
on m'a appelé pour un entretien mais je
sais pas ce qu'ils ont vu dans mon dos
et les pots pour bébés nés et cela où il
m'a dit toi tu dois être français je
regarde maman ici en france on n'a
jamais dit que j'étais français
léger il lui dit peut-être par rapport à
l'accent non commence a dit c'est ta
façon de penser j'ai dit ok du coup les
français vous êtes les seuls dans ce
ventre à vous mettre des barrières dans
la tête ces personnes qui vont appeler
ce sont les professionnels même si vous
manquez dans votre cv
vous irez à montrer qu ils sauront ils
seront dès ce n'est que vous leur avez
grandi mais le fait quand tu es appelé
c'est qu'ils ont trouvé quelque chose
dans ce but est donc ce que tu peux
faire jusque là et vite évident de faire
le français de français étant selon lui
que j'allais peut-être trouvé une castro
a inventé pour ne pas gêner dans le plan
des caps où il ya les peines à tête
baissée et écrire on m'a dit jusqu'à
présent fait ce que tu as à faire nos
ici ambiante le meilleur enseignant
c'est le google on va sur google et tu
dis ce que tu dois étudier à l'entretien
donc le meilleur sous donc de meilleurs
de table et surtout ne te dis pas que tu
dois pas mal si on laisse le peut nestlé
peut dire non et obion d'écriture
ajustons en anglais chez merci pour le
continuation
quoi de pire éliminez vos barrières dans
la tête et depuis qu'ils ont a dit ça je
suis allé j'ai réussi le test
je ne sais pas comment on amène en
formation dans un vrai dans un vrai
c'était dans un tribut dans la aussi la
barrière radiante parce que l'anglais
partait à toute vitesse compris
m mais j'avais toujours en tête est
l'une des barrières mais cela peut te
dire non et surtout pas à toi de te dire
et depuis que j'ai eu cette phrase
sampler ça m'a permis déjà d'être et
surtout je laisse les autres de guerre
on savait la société a tellement de bas
riant lorsque la société vous met des
barrières efficaces et vous y rester
elle peut être d'ordre psychologique ça
peut être des préjugés mais derrière des
barrières comme l'a dit c'est ça que
vous mettez dans la tête
donc quand ils fassent éliminer par
ailleurs dans ma tête et surtout ce
qu'on dit fête est un préambule
donc ça c'est le premier conseil que je
vous donnais éliminer vos pariant ma
tête ça nous déroute deuxième de dire
qu'on sait c'est être déterminée c'est
pas ne s'est pas déterminés c'est pas
être déterminée vous voyez la photo je
vais vous je vais vous dire c'est un peu
d'actualité s'est pas déterminés vous
avez juste un petit blocage ou jamais
c'est pas vous passer le permis
on vous dit que vous n'avez pas le
permis de conduire ne vous arrêtez
toutes nos têtes avaient laissé aller au
delà
je vous raconte juste l'histoire
l'histoire peut se dessiner grand que
j'ai rencontré d'habitude on en dira aux
migrants vous êtes fatigués ici penser à
rentrer au pays c'est mieux et ce jour
là il ya eu un migrant c'était en plein
hiver il va désormais cyber contre il me
disait qu'il tend l'est sous des
cagoules et ont directement les grands
ducs août espagne vie ce que vous faites
là est ce que si on cherche
pour que vous puissiez après vous allez
accepter de ce migrant je me souviens de
lui me disait jamais là et demi plus
tard je le rencontre à la poste comme
par hasard il a bien fait il me voit il
se met à pleurer
voyez les feuilles ouest à des gens qui
se passait du côté des frais de
transports restent en jeu ne se dit pas
on y va du dernier les capotes moquette
pour qu'ils se mettent à pleurer
il vient de rentrer et me montre son
voisin du nord
il y avait 400 euros qui l'envoyaient à
sa mère et je dis oui mais pourquoi plus
writing c'est dieu qui t'envoient tu te
rappelles quand tu nous a proposé dans
votre chambre
il faut que je te raconte pas des sous
quand j'étais au pays d'avoir un jour ma
mère est tombée malade
comme j'étais au chômage je n'avais
aucune aucun de la dernière c'est mon
ami d'en face la monnaie mondiale à
l'hôpital
ce jour là j'ai mis la honte de ma vie
et je me suis dit plus jamais ça je le
sais mais à traverser ils sont reçus à
l'air en débit ces traversées
je suis allé dans les crapauds en italie
vous à cracher dessus nous en fait t on
nous a arrêtés je suis venu en france
ici non vous avez vu jérôme et martin
entre deux cadres mais j'avais juste une
seule chose en tête
plus jamais ça craint j'étais déterminé
au point où j'allais maintenant que tu
me vois aujourd'hui 2,1 en effet après
voilà le premier 300 euros que je
croyais
là ça va contre une façon de dire que
rien ne l'avait empêchée d'aller tout
dans cet état nation et je vous donne
juste cette définition que nestlé mardi
en raison la détermination de jouer où
vous faites quelque chose que vous
n'avez pas envie de faire pour le faire
j'ai donc juste deux exemples fait une
soirée vous inviter beaucoup d'amis et
vous vous dites en vaut peut être que la
17e vous laisser chez vous ne tombera
jamais c'est à chaque jour vous allez
faire votre message
et ce soir-là et mechhed 3 heures du
matin vous raccompagner voter revient
habiter ou entrez vous faire maintenant
pour vous montrer de voiliers mode
cuisine là des cintres la détermination
et ne cessa de moody's laisse demain je
vais me coucher
ou alors vous vous dites malgré tout je
veux faire c'est que ce soit la
détermination ça peut être aussi ici on
vous amène à l'aéroport on vous dit
d'aller chercher une tente à l'aéroport
à 3 heures du matin n'importe qui
d'entre vous trouvera toute excuse pour
ne pas y aller abattre on ne retourne
pas ouais elle se débrouille qu'attendu
berges du nord en bourse mais sauf si on
vous dit maintenant que vous devez
rencontrer à une enveloppe de 1000 euros
pour vous trois heures du matin
votre détermination fera que vous
n'aurez n'ont pas besoin à 0,6 à la loi
donc c'est exactement ça aide des
terminales je ne dis pas que tout est
rose
il ya des moments où vous serez dans un
tunnel lorsque vous entrez dans aucune
des ouvertures vous entre mais lorsqu'à
dans ce qu'on construit en chine est une
senti il a des fois vous allez être dans
le noir total
il des fois vous ne réussissez pas à
vous voyez tout
si vous optez qu'est-ce qui se passe il
ya des moments vous avez envie de faire
des choses vous allez échoué vous allez
dire mais c'est pas possible
alors que vous regardez une autre
personne russie mais lorsque vous
attendez tunnel on aura tous des
périodes noires
la seule chose à ne pas verser de ce
soir que se dire je suis fatigué de
toutes les traces relevées y aller parce
qu'il ya une sortie aux poings mais non
plus parce qu'on fait c'est des connards
d'obstacles on s'arrête et on n'y va pas
donc ne vous découragez pas quelle que
soit la personne vos amis on parle pour
proches ou des préjugés
l'important déjà plus lorsque vous avez
chose en tête voulaient devenir bilingue
en anglais que vous nous donner des
rendez-vous des rendez vous par exemple
la crédit à 20h bfm a créé 10 à 20 ans
je passe une heure de temps un ferme en
anglais si ce jour là vous tombez sur la
finale de la champion's league
soyez soyez prioritaire allez-y au
rendez vous de votre de votre anglais
ils n'aident personne personne vous dire
ce que vous en avez donc été menée cette
année jusqu'au bout enfin la gemmi la
carte de l'afrique où là on connaissait
ce que vous connaissez un peu moi c'est
le drapeau du sénégal
c'est limpide j'aime y soyons fiers et
je vais tout d'abord vous dire qu'aux
lecteurs de nous connecter pour vous
connecter
ce n'est pas sympa dans compterait
toujours des personnes pessimiste au
départ sont désagréables alors une
première chose que je me demande c'est
positif et rejoignent je vous raconte
juste cette histoire ça a été au matin
il est allé dans ce pays n'aura pour moi
c'est ce qu'on vous connaissez donc
toute cette histoire de gier aussi et je
n'ai pas du tout envie
jusqu'au jour où j'arrive tous les
matins il y avait personne à l'hôtel
saison du matin disait papa a gravi chez
we be en croyant que il voulait me dire
est ce que tu as une rapide tous les
films en temps je faisais ya des styles
et tous les matins c'est comme ça arabi
ya saillants et il me répondait sans
abri
tous les matins jusqu'au jour où une
visite ne veut rien
cette personne était toujours joyeuse
toujours dynamique toujours heureux et
ce journal dans ce qu'on disait de
mémorial c'est normal c'était un million
de morts en trois mois
assassiner des tutsi comme on en était
un échappement que vous rencontrez de
cette année là bas en tout cela des
personnes qui connaissaient peut-être
cornet qui disait pour vivre chaque jour
comme si c'était le dernier
c'était état d'esprit de tout un chacun
a lancé lula on arrive on regarde 10
possibles ou probables de l'histoire est
vue humain il arriva le moment il se met
à pleurer ils disent assez bonne
histoire on dit quoi et des écoutes
comment ça ça démarrait je rentrais chez
moi je rentrais chez moi et on a un
moment joue au football et on n'a pas
d'aidé des sont comme des petites on a
compris que c'était eux qui vont avec
les couteaux les ce qu'ils avaient pour
tuer donc il a free il dit sais pas
comment il servait il est remis dès et
en allant dans son village il avait vu
plein de damas il regarde il
reconnaissait tout acquis peptac nommant
une jambe n'a pas toute sa famille assad
me regarde cm3 qui s'est elle a milk sea
soyons mais comment fais tu pour avoir
ça va fait vous savez dans cette
situation avant toute chose de façon de
voir les choses
chaque anniversaire qui passe chaque
moment j'ai la haine mais j'ai choisi de
nous avons deux voies dans la voix
négatif et là vous vous envolez vous
pouvez devenir méchant vous pouvez la
voir positive et j'ai choisi cette voie
touristique
alors si tu me regardes sourire ceux qui
ont connu mardi
c'est le souvenir de ces bannières qui
souvient travail si vous voyez un marché
dynamique mens comme tu le dis c'est
parce que c'est mon frère qui marchande
et si vous voyez aussi le beau c'est
parce que je suis mon coeur c'est ma
façon de rendre hommage mais pas si je
te dis tous les matins à leurs habits
jeter m'a demandé est ce que tu vas bien
parce que là tu veux dire mécaniquement
envie ça va mais à leurs habits et que
tu meures a produit un saillant ça veut
dire tout simplement que tu positivement
jeudi soir
ce qui veut dire que tu ne perds sont
positifs et j'ai décidé de vivre qu'avec
des personnes aux it if donc ça c'est sa
façon de voir les choses
donc soyons positifs soyons heureux
soyons fiers de toutes les identités qui
n'osaient moi je suis du serial et j'en
suis fier de la patinoire et cet aspect
je viens de ce continent africain et
n'importe que je vous amène dans ce
continent sera est rien comme vous y
allez
et vous allez rencontrer je dirais pas
la plus belle plage dans meego loin
l'honneur est aussi l'accueil que tout
africain pour vous apporter
mercredi donc ça c'est je suis cher
certes mais en me disant c'est pas parce
que la fixer dont je voudrais que vous
mais aussi de notre côté on dit
tout c'est parce que tu sais comment je
sais pas mais vient aussi chez moi dans
ma le temps barre franche comté c'est
juste pour larry et je vais te faire
découvrir comme ça ces façons de nous
connecter
soyons fiers de toutes nos zones régies
et la dernière chose pour terminer je
voudrais qu'on puisse se connecter ce
que j'appelle contexte tendu mais pas de
manière virtuelle juste de manière
humaine
je voudrais que toute la salle saynètes
salut prennent la balle de son voisin
maxime ne connaissent pas connecté
connectez vous
connectez vous parce qu'on a plus de
choses à partager pour des cons parce
qu'on s'enrichit des cultures deux
autres poteries ne pas être paresseux
pour ma réussite et votre site
connecte-toi l'eau parce que c'est le
seul moyen de changer le monde parce que
c'est vous même qui peuvent changer se
montre enfin lorsque vous et à vous y
arrivez si vous c'est beau tout simple
une perte de temps et loi sur le maire
automatiquement il ne faudrait pas
tomber
c'est ça la solidarité c'est pour ça que
je vous demande de vous connecter
et dernière chose j'espère que je vais
vous entendre vous connaissez la réponse
est je vais juste vous entendez dire au
revoir
je vais vous poser cette question et je
veux voir si vous avez appris
centralement ailleurs a dit merci à vous
[Applaudissements]